[Music]
in poopoo panic news oh there's been a
few of those before submitted by Billy
silly a woman got trapped in a double
pane window at her tinder dates house
after trying to hide her poop is that
real I saw this is that real good 3 I
saw the article I didn't read it well
how do you get trapped inside a double
pane window we're gonna fly like this
wait what
The Shining - where's the poop she did
it not flush as you try throw it out
exactly did I oh Jesus Christ why would
you try to throw up whoo I know the
smell is still there the first date
thing is [ __ ] weird
why not flush it is such a big [ __ ] she
took her hands in the toilet and she
wouldn't help the [ __ ] window but she
fell and got [ __ ] funny about this
the picture yeah I'm all ears on this
one so liam is the guy and the girl we
don't know her name do you guys want to
name her
Oh Bridget Bridget what's one demerit
Pappas one of yours ok which one I knew
they do ok so we haven't
they went on the date they went to
Nando's I love those Mexican food
no the chicken plate oh this is the UK
sorry
have you tried Nando's I've heard of it
I've heard of it pretty fun really good
yeah so they went to the date and then
they had a good time so they decided to
cut like you know go up to hit Liam's
place and have a drink and watch a movie
and so while they're in their date she
excused herself she went to the restroom
she took a [ __ ] she panicked
because the toilet wasn't flushing so
she reached in with the tissue paper
grabbed her poop she opened the window
thinking that it would just disappear
right but she didn't realize that this
window it was it has a double pane and
what happened was her she got stuck it
got stuck between the two the two
windows she went out she went outside
she told Liam she was just like you know
I'm so sorry this is what happened and
so she told him what happened oh yeah so
then he was like alright no problem let
me hit up the housemates um the text
message to let them know that I'm gonna
have to break the window to try to get
it and she was like no no cuz apparently
she's an amateur gymnast so she was like
no I think I could do it so then that's
when she climbed in and she reached over
she grabbed a piece of poop plug it over
the window and if the Liam came over to
try to help her and so apparently when
he was trying to pull her out by the way
she was stuck so then they waited like
they were trying to get her out for the
15 minutes so finally he started getting
he started getting worried about her
that's when they called the fire
department and they came
they had to break the window it must
have smelled so bad foggy on steamier
she deserves a second date come on Mary
this is a [ __ ] story bad picture has
to be shown at the one area oh yeah
she's smiling good he looks like a good
guy he was like he would tolerate that
actually like it's just like I'm not
Wednesday from Leon said that they did
have a second date because yeah I ended
up meeting together to create a a
crowdfunding page to be able to get
enough money to pay for the new window
because that's dude and he's like I
can't afford this but then I was
thinking why isn't she paying for it
whatever cuz she a normal picture of her
instead of her like but how do you
explain that on GoFundMe did they tell
the story no yeah he told a beautifully
written story it was so funny
um it's like the whole story I'm sure I
understand how this window works how
yeah I don't window is this like a
double sided maybe enough to fit a
person I don't know is UK windows
panels can do this ya know like one of
them just doesn't even open what so what
do you know I don't get it either it's
really weird it's like a double window
believe it it's a window
but you could she fit her body and she
went headfirst yes who's the show screen
you on a first date is crazy all over a
person - impressive first day ellicott
is so weird like I think guys we pee on
the side of the bowl so we don't make
any noise yeah as if they don't know
what's going on in there we're just
laying pee on the side of them now you
run the water in the water yeah ladies
have you don't approve that big where
you're like panicking like oh no I gotta
break it up oh yeah well not break it up
but how big was it has your biggest
pooping I was actually surprised at how
big of a poop I can actually take like
describing doesn't like a log like this
like what is it your obsession what was
it wait go ahead do today it was a long
I like this painting Oh what I ate who
doesn't face him what about you I don't
know me but you won't know what you
can't flush it yeah really
no it's because the water pressure in
our house is really like [ __ ] yeah but I
learned and this might save some lives
out there that if you have a poop that
clogs your toilet boil water and pour it
in there because it breaks on all the
fats in the poop and then it melts it
off into smaller pieces yeah you say
that in the camera yeah we know we know
about that the problem is is I don't
want to put hot water on a steaming pile
of [ __ ]
right it would stink up the whole house
yeah cuz the steam yeah yeah like when
you Mart in a hot shower yeah God that
feels good though huh sorry I Dutch
topping myself inside a shower before
it's hard to get rid of the smell yeah
do you guys party yeah there's a rule
not too far you never fart yeah I like
to pack better than there we don't fart
in front of each other but it doesn't
mean that we have ass whipped one and
slip before I think I don't on our third
like night in bed I think it weighted it
a little bit yeah I think I turned it in
front of you before you're like it's
just fart
kinda like told you like can we please
have like some sort of understanding
here where we don't fight in front each
other because I'm gonna lose all respect
for this day I can't do it because I've
been in relationships before where they
just fart I'll save my farts are under a
blanket I store my farts story and then
I'll go like that cuz it really it's
like a say before it say before I'm so
like smell it and then like like that
and then I'll smell some you enjoy your
own fart
I don't know why am I the only one I
don't I don't enjoy it but then if I
smell it it smells bad are you angry at
myself I try to fight myself like what
the [ __ ] do you think you are bro but it
smells terrible
you're not one scene from a superstar oh
oh are you that won't get that kind of
guy
Molly Shannon she puts her hands under
her arm yeah and she relishes in it you
know but a farts different than your
armpits I mean yeah smell my own farts
can you can you do you guys he's a
bathroom front of each other no no what
did what about pooing no no you people
showering yeah so what's the pet peeves
like what what like what's hard to deal
with in the in this situation like what
like takes you off in what tips do you
offer like what she does I think the
biggest thing is I'm a morning person
she's a night person so it's like I wake
up like 7:00 a.m. that's just going in
like noon no no lucky Levin
12:30 no no no yeah and then we're
always on opposite schedules yeah yeah
but you wake up at 4 p.m. I'm just
vampire yeah I don't know when it
started I I just I can't sleep I have to
you know I'm the only person where on
filming days she has to call me an hour
and I had to make sure I'm awake
no this one oh really into okay it's
morning you had to call both of you know
my god she missed like she's overslept
before yeah both of them you will
reflect yeah that's all and then how mad
do you guys are you yelling like what
the flowery much
I always show up fifteen minutes late
but I show a 50 limits late minutes late
to the call time but then we only start
30 minutes after so technically I'm
still early you're not I am
I'm still early no but yeah I don't
blame this girlfriend not wanting to
come out I would be derelict I can't I
can't do it I would be borderline
jumping off a bridge out of
embarrassment imagine her identity came
out by accident how embarrassed would he
feel oh that would not hurt her
it's a human thing it's poo fine she got
caught throw another one oh whatever but
getting stuck in the windowpane like
that's embarrassing sad like I'm sorry
girl like listen Barry if KC ripped one
right now let allowed s1 like his
attractive level will go down yes
about how much she said respect and
respect so after he goes respect what's
the view or a [ __ ] low control
himself virtual gas no it's a human
thing how about you kissing kissing is
there anything that she would do like
yeah I know some guys who are like I
love seeing you get all dressed up and
pretty but just don't let me see when
you take it all down like are you weird
about that no cuz I had a guy once more
I took out my York Sun she's easy and
then he lied to him huh he thought it
was a real hair [ __ ] glad he's seen many
Fortune pictures of me Asian oh my god
because if you just purposely farted in
front of me you know I'd get pissed so
she like pulled out her tampon in front
of you a girl wants to see that I did
see this video of this Asian lady in a
subway scratching her [ __ ] and she kept
on smelling it anyone's gonna reply
button what the dingleberry yeah
it was okay let me this is her ass right
yeah it wasn't like one of those like
scratches it was like in there and she
was just digging
why was she doing that she really eating
it she was eating her poo or some [ __ ]
but this girl had that Asian subway was
[ __ ] hilarious because she was I cuz
you know when somebody scratches they
use one hand she was going left and
right so she's like bow bow bow bow bow
bow I should get going Shan can take
some le er yeah I was like what the [ __ ]
is this girl do he just likes weird
smells
you should she was like not don't think
so I just think she look like a regular
Asian person maybe I'm not very good I
have worms in second grade I used to dig
my ass like that weren't you what worms
umm playground and then you don't wash
your hands and you eat [ __ ] oh my
parents have to like put vinegar up my
ass holy [ __ ] it's got to tape you I
think you could you put scotch tape at
night when you're sleep and then one of
them might get stuck like the warm cuz
they'll come out and you'll get stuck to
the tape they come out of the ring out
of your butthole and it tickles
you can vinegar work I think so are you
still at warm says thanks mom
so like them Wrigley around me your
buckets you have that was collars a
[ __ ] bucket you oh yeah I dig down
dig down just try to get both hands back
yeah you too brother
you have yet the worms too big my ass
yep no pick me I don't know any kid that
doesn't pick their ass I'll do it the
worst is when I got out even though how
the [ __ ] this happened on a how I got in
there I got a mosquito bite right next
my butthole what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] leaks at the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
other than that videos are up there
[Music]
you
[Music]